I love this story about like Eddie
Murphy is special
that's a great story but it is but it
took balls right you know I had started
a DVD company to sell DVDs back when
people were buying free Netflix
completely yeah pre Netflix well Netflix
was DVDs at the beginning right so I was
uh and Eddie and I uh our buddies going
back to when we were 18 19 years old so
we're in his kitchen and I said I
started this DVD company
and I said what do you own
he said I don't only thing I own is my
stand-up where I'm in a red leather
outfit
I go that's it he goes yeah we're at
leather outfit I did it for HBO and they
gave me 50 Grand raw uh no that was
delirious delirious delirious and I said
oh I said I'd like to put it out on DVD
so he says okay call my lawyers so I
called the lawyers and I said Eddie and
I were in his kitchen last night I told
him I wanted to put you know delirious
out on DVD
and I said you have any offers like oh
yeah we have an offer from Lionsgate
for seven hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
and I said well how much money would I
have to pay you
to get the rights to put this on DVD and
you don't go with Lionsgate for 750.
and the lawyer says
1.1 million one just out of just like he
just laid in on me 1.1 million 350 Grand
more than Lions game
and I said and I kind of pause
I said if I give you 1.1 million can I
get the rights to put it on DVD and then
he was like whoa because I think he
thought the number was going to scare me
right
and then he says to me
1.1 million up front
like you wire me the money day one this
is what the lawyer says I said if I gave
you 1.1 million up front day one are we
good
he goes yeah it was like that I said
okay we have a deal I'll give you 1.1
million up front
and so
I did not have two nickels to rub
together
at that time
and so I went to the manufacturer of the
DVDs who manufactures DVDs and I said I
got a big order from you for you I'm
gonna order a lot of DVDs I said I just
got the rights to Eddie Murphy's
delirious
and they went whoa I go yeah we're gonna
sell a lot of DVDs great I said I just
need one thing from you he goes what's
that I said I need you to send me 1.1
million today
oh my God so the guy goes whoa okay and
I convinced the guy to send me 1.1
million as an advance for the orders for
the DVDs so I wire the money to Eddie
and I call and then my sales people go
to sell the DVDs
and my salesperson called me back right
after I wired the money and said I got
bad news for you
really bad news for you
I go what because I cannot afford bad
news
and he goes
um
Walmart only wants to put Eddie in the
black stores
the black zip codes stores in the black
zip codes I got a 4 000 stores they only
want to put them in 400 of them
Alan are you serious white people don't
know Eddie Murphy that's exactly what I
said I said why people love Eddie Murphy
what are we talking probably more white
people from Personnel 40 Saturday Night
Live 48 Hours Trading Places Beverly
Hills Cop I was like are you serious you
know literally we're just going to do
400 stores out of 4
000. yep
so I said all right A buddy of mine
happened to be on the board of of
Walmart Chris Williams right and I said
Chris I need your help I just wired
Eddie Murphy 1.1 million that I don't
have
and uh I said Walmart the biggest seller
of DVDs just pretty much shut me down
and this thing's about to crash and burn
and I need Eddie Murphy in all stores
not just the stores in the black zip
codes
and he said hold on and I hear him
typing blah blah blah he says don't
worry I got it I got a call
just less than an hour later
and the guy says oh one of our board
members she said we should connect
no problem and they put the DVD in all
stores
and it ended up being the biggest
selling DVD at Walmart that wasn't a
theatrical motion picture
it couldn't stay on the shelf
it just kept flying off the shelf we
brought in tens of millions of dollars
just at Walmart wow on that DVD wow that
he got paid 50 Grand to do just 10 years
earlier because but he got the 1.1 and
then you and kept sending money oh you
did oh yeah oh yeah yeah you're kidding
me yeah yeah you're kidding me
absolutely it was uh it was a very nice
it was a great deal for Eddie it was a
great deal for us
[Music]